it might only be January but it's
already time to look ahead to pool
season yes when nightlife recently held
their auditions for the upcoming season
and I went behind the scenes to see what
the whole process is like check it out
welcome to the fabulous 2023 win
nightlife auditions I'm gonna head
inside and see what it takes to make the
cut when nightlife houses a portfolio of
globally recognized day life and
nightlife destinations
but if you've ever wondered what it
takes to get a job at one of these
venues here's an inside look
foreign
auditions are held over two days after
applying online it's time for the
in-person experience girls or guys will
be able to come in experience everything
in its entirety we have photo moments we
have photo booths we have activations
that display our future events like we
have in here we're sitting inside the
arm of the wild box right now which is
the event's going to take place in March
but everybody can experience everything
there are a variety of positions up for
grabs prospective candidates can like to
be a marketing model position which
includes cocktail servers bartenders for
our apprentices server assistance and
then we have lifeguards and security
guards this isn't your traditional job
interview the audition room is filled
with a lot of installations and
experiences while some are new to the
process and some are returning
candidates they all have to go through
the same auditions so every year because
it's a seasonal position you have to
reaction
but I mean once you've done it it's
smooth and again you just have to come
in here with confidence and you'll be
fine Natalie has been working for wind
nightlife for eight years and says
there's never a dull moment every day is
so different and the culture that we
have here is amazing our DJ lineup is
incredible we get to meet people from
all over the world we have a very team
atmosphere and we all are here for the
same goal which is to provide five-star
service and we truly are a family here
so that's why I love coming back what
Drew you to audition and what was that
process like for you yeah I actually
wasn't living here in Las Vegas I was
living back in Reno and I saw the Flyers
and I decided to come down I flew down
for interviews and luckily I got the job
with no experience so if you're just
honest and you're upbeat you have energy
I mean you definitely have the
opportunity to work at an amazing place
like this the interview process is less
about experience and more about
personality we don't like standard
interviews
fun fact and prior work experience which
is extremely relevant for us to be able
to dictate well I'm having a lot of fun
in here but the line is wrapped around
the room so I think we should go check
it out see some of the girls that are
auditioning and wish them luck what do
you think let's do it all right let's go
do it well we have made our way to the
long line of beautiful ladies behind us
tell us what's going on here they're
taking photos what's going on so this is
part of the audition process that we
have here girls with check in sign an
informational card I'm up and send an
information a card they'll wait to
return then they'll take one of the
photos so photos for us to be able to
recollect exactly who came and then be
able to filter everything out other than
that after photo opportunities when they
go sit and then wait for them congrats
to all these beautiful women behind us I
bet we'll be seeing a lot of them out at
the pool what do you think
wow what uh I mean what a popular
position so many people were there yeah
and it goes over two days which is
amazing they said they get thousands of
applicants and I really liked talking
with Natalie who is returning for her
eighth year and she said even if you
have no experience you just have to come
in show your your personality you know
do the interview process but it's not
anything to be nervous about it was fun
in there it's like a party it looked
like a big party did any men apply were
there any guys as the day went on there
were other positions to feel like
lifeguards and security and other things
so that was kind of heavy on the women
at the moment but as the day went on
other guys were showing up I'm sure they
were having a lot of fun in there cool
season right around the corner to
believe all right well more than 1100
exhibitors were on hand for the winter